قال مدافع وست هام، نايف أجارد، إن فريق
هامرز فاز
على تشيلسي بنتيجة 3-1 خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع،
وقال اللاعب البالغ من العمر 27 عامًا إنه مر 12 شهرًا بعد
مساعدة المغرب على المضي قدمًا في تلك المسيرة التاريخية
في كأس العالم في قطر وفي البطولة
الأفريقية هذا الشهر.  سلسلة أصوات صانع الألعاب،
حارس يتحدث مع أحد كبار المحللين الرياضيين لدينا
دارين لويس حول
مسيرته المذهلة في كأس العالم وكيف ساعدت والدته في
تشكيله ليصبح الرجل الذي هو عليه اليوم
بالنسبة لي في كرة القدم
كلاعب كرة قدم، أنت بحاجة للعب
كأس العالم ودوري أبطال أوروبا  إنها
المنافسة الجريئة التي يمكن أن تخوضها في هذا المجال في
كرة القدم،
وباعتبارنا أفارقة، نعلم أن الأمر صعب للغاية
لأنه حتى للتأهل إلى كأس العالم،
فإنك تلعب الكثير من المباريات ثم
تحتاج إلى إنهاء المباراة أولاً، ثم تحتاج أولاً إلى
لعب مباراتين أخريين.  المباريات ذهابًا وإيابًا
لذلك يكون من الصعب التأهل وعندما تكون
في منافسة،
فأنت لست العالم، لا
تقلل من شأننا لأن هذا ليس صحيحًا
ولكن
بينما نسير كما لو أننا لا نملك الكثير من
الثقة التي لا نريدها  أن نضغط أكثر
لأننا خائفون ونخشى أن نأتي
من بلدان أخرى ولهذا السبب
أريد أن أقول في المغرب كانت لدينا فرصة
ليكون لدينا مدير مثل واليدر جريجي
أعرفه منذ 17 عامًا
ولا أريد التحدث  عنه
كشخص لأنني لن أتوقف، إنه أمر لا
يصدق فهو يعرف كل لاعب
وهو قريب جدًا من لاعبيه
وهو أيضًا في التفاصيل كإنسان
يمكنك الحضور إلى التدريب
ويمكنه معرفة ما إذا كنت جيدًا أم لا  ليس جيدًا،
يمكنه مساعدتك خارج الملعب وبالنسبة
لي، هذه هي كرة القدم لأننا حسنًا، نحن نلعب
كرة القدم ونركض ونريد الفوز
بالمال والألقاب وكل شيء ولكن
الأهم بعد كرة القدم هو
الرجل الذي يمكنني الذهاب إليه لأخذ قسط من الراحة  تناول القهوة معه
لأنه رجل لطيف وكرة القدم
أمر لا يصدق، فهو وأمك
أكثر
شخصين تأثيرًا في حياتك، نعم تحدث معي عن
والدتك، ما مدى تأثيرها
بالنسبة لي، إنها امرأة خارقة بالنسبة لي، لقد فعلت كل شيء،
فعلت
كل شيء  الآن لم أكبر ونشأ
في عائلة غنية لكنها أخبرتني
بشيء
لا أستطيع أن أقوله أبدًا أنا فقير
لأنها كانت دائمًا تقول
لا تقل فقير لأنك لا تفكر إلا
في المال لكننا لسنا فقراء لديك
صحتك أنت
ذكي يمكنك القيام بالدراسات أنت
جيد لماذا لديك ثلاثة
ذكور في اليوم لماذا تقول فقير
ولكن لكي
أكون صادقا في داخلي قلت
نحن فقراء لكنها قالت يمكنك التفكير
ولكن لا تقل ذلك  هذا هو كل شيء
بالنسبة لي، فهو يساعد الناس على فهم سبب
رقص اللاعبين المغاربة مع أمهاتهم
بعد المباراة ضد البرتغال. أخبرني
أنه
لم يكن شيئًا نلعبه
قبل المنافسة
لأنك
تعرف متى تكون في الملعب.  المدرسة
أعطيك مثالاً عندما تذهب إلى
المدرسة ثم يكون
لديك يوم جيد كيف تقول باللغة
الإنجليزية امتحان جيد امتحان جيد تنجح في
اختبار أو شيء أول شخص
تقول له
أنا رجل حتى لا تذهب  وتقول
لوالدك تذهب إلى والدتك فهذا أمر
طبيعي
هكذا هو الحال في كرة القدم فزنا في
المباراة الأولى وترى والدتك
تشاهد المباراة بالطبع هل أنت
مثل الطفل تريد أن ترقص مع
والدتك التي تريدها  لأخبرها أنني سعيد جدًا لأننا
فعلنا ذلك وكان هذا فقط والآن إذا
كنت عندما أتحدث مع أمي، فهي
دائمًا تقول متى ستكون
المسابقة التالية، لا، إنها بخير، إنها
بالفعل في المنافسة الأخرى، قلت
لها نعم ولكن  هذا الكائن لم يكن موجودًا في
كل الساحل إذا كنت تريد
الاستيلاء عليه، نعم سنأتي، ستأتي بالطبع لا، إنه أمر
لا يصدق وسيكون لدى الكثير من
اللاعبين أهداف، نعم
أنا لا أتحدث عن الجوائز أو الأندية لا أنا
أتحدث  عن
هدف لك مع نفسك
هدف شخصي وبالنسبة لي شخصياً
هدفي هو أن أجعل أمي فخورة بي منذ أن كنت
صغيراً ولن أتوقف عمري 27
وحتى لو كان عمري 35 هدفي هو أن أصنع
فخراً ومتى  عندما أتوقف عن كرة القدم، أختار
أن أفعل شيئًا آخر،
وسيظل كذلك دائمًا حتى النهاية